-Trump made an unplanned visit
to Walter Reed Medical Cente
on Saturday.
He tweeted he was there
to visit the family
of a young man having surgery.
And while he was there, he said,
"Also began phase one
of my yearly physical.
Everything very good. Great.
[ Laughter ]
Phase one of a physical?
That sounded strange.
So we did some digging
and discovered
that his annual physical
has five phases.
So let's take a look now
at the five phases of
Donald Trump's annual physical
Phase one, measure
his official height
and negotiate
his official weight.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Phase two,
a complete strip, spackle,
priming, and repainting.
Phase three, his annual batter
of paternity tests.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Phase four, surgically remov
his hand from a Nutella jar.
And finally, phase five, ask
about getting breast implants.
Not the procedure -- He just
wants to play around with them
[ Laughter, applause ]
This has been the five phase
of Donald Trump's
annual physical.